chocolats biscuits vêtements ou encore
décoration environ 80 exposants étaient
répartis dans des halles couvertes dans
le parc du domaine de madame elisabeth à
versailles quatrième édition du comptoir
de noël le service des espaces verts des
yvelines a créé également et celle de
noël c'est un parti fait huit hectares
en vainqueur de versailles le domaine de
madame isabelle l'avantagé qu'on connaît
ce lieu parfaitement l'idée c'est
vraiment de répartir au maximum ce
nombre de personnes à travers
différentes séquences les différentes
scènes de façon indigne et le fus et
surtout avoir des animations de partout
parmi les exposants 80% sont yvelinois
comme l'entreprise les ruchers
d'alexandre situé dans la région du
vexin il propose du miel du pain des
pistes ou encore des sucettes janvier
des fois ils s'arrêtent les questions
plus de 20000 visiteurs sont venus ce
week end au comptoir de noël avec des
idées précises en tête on est venu au
comptoir vent nous on a pensé de marché
de noël on émouvoir les petits achats
noël et ont trouvé des produits logo
c'était possible
hier je te conseille et nous savions que
nous allions retrouver des stands
il
je sortais de nous
ces cinq mesures le 18 et 19 décembre
les animations comme le père noël ou le
labyrinthe seront encore présentes sur
le site récent le marché de noël